one of the issues at the heart of the
winter scandal is what information is
presented to ministers and what is dealt
with buying officials at Lord Kelly was
head of the home several service between
2012 to 2015 and I'm delighted to say
joins me know what Christ like thank you
for being with us and in your mind is it
conceivable that either this woman
secretary or the last Home Secretary
what unaware of those targets around
illegal immigrants well let's put this
way I find it very surprising now there
could be one memo the one that she says
she hasn't seen that went into her
office but didn't get into a box
there are hundreds if not thousands of
emails and memos that go into the
private office what I find very
surprising is that there wasn't some
briefing to the minister when she went
before the Select Committee or indeed
other committees so I think the question
she's going to be asked tomorrow is not
were you aware this particular memo but
will you brief to any point on the issue
of my of deportations and targets yeah I
mean in that memo it says adds a
supplementary points but progress has
been made on a path towards the ten
percent increase to performance and
enforce returns which we promised the
Home Secretary earlier this needed now
when you read when you hear something
like that
do you take it to mean that an official
briefed the Home Secretary directly well
if you say you promised it to the Home
Secretary then it follows that some kind
of information must have gone either to
the Home Secretary or one of her special
advisers and as I say even if it wasn't
done in that way you would never put a
minister in front of a select committee
without properly briefing them on the
issues we are them just as does
responsibility lie I mean we do seem to
be through the looking-glass and so much
and so much of politics these days
ministers used to resign for quite a lot
less by my reckoning but we do see an
awful lot of the book being passed to to
those officials and we do you think
unfairly I think so actually I am
concerned about this there's been much
less of the noises off that there were
when I was head of the social service a
really quite corrosive period it has to
be said but I think when the chips are
down ministers have to take
responsibility it is their department
after all privately they may well say to
a civil servant look I'm not happy this
handled well but the whole deal if you
like is that the ministry is responsible
they take credit for the things that go
well and they take responsibility for
the things that don't go well I mean I
just want to read your tweet from the MP
Julian Smith he says the UK civil
service is helping to deliver brexit the
quality of support and advices
world-class attacking individual civil
servants is deeply unfair that's now
being retweeted by Teresa mains chief of
staff Gavin Barr well who if we believe
accounts in the papers today had
something of a set-to with David Davis I
mean have you ever known politicians and
the civil service to be saw on oh yes
there have have been at odds in the past
and as I say when I was head of the
scissors we had a very difficult time
because what we were getting were what I
called noises off unofficial briefings
about the civil service and and their
ability and I think there's been less of
that but Julian is right there you
cannot be in a situation where a civil
servants are put in put to the sword and
they're not and sister keep are in a
position to respond they can't go to the
mail order or the Telegraph or whatever
and say I hope the Catholic memos which
it's not I'm not suggesting that's
happening in this occasion but they can
leak members committee can but again on
brexit the civil service does appear to
be coming in for a huge amount of flack
what do you think that the civil
services Ramin look up until a few years
ago we have to remember that was
substantive government policy so all
civil servants back to then government
policy of trying to stay in the European
Union we have seen a remarkable shift in
recent years and civil service have had
to come to terms with that but and this
is the point they pride themselves on
being professionals in doing the job of
supporting the government of the day so
they will be wanting to deliver a good
Brax it because that is the government's
policy is still at the same time you
know when the House of Lords defeated
the government and the customs union the
week before last
every living former cabinet secretary
voted against the government Armstrong
Butler Wilson Turnbull O'Donnell what
care who proposed it the amendment you
know who's joined in voting against the
government buys to successors of the
Foreign Office it does seem like the
father those who have moved on from the
civil service are doing the very best to
stymie the process of practice
well I don't think so because the votes
against the brexit bill are not in a
sense saying brexit cannot happen
they're saying if it happens it has to
be done in a way that doesn't damage the
interests of this country and as peers
as lords they're entitled to challenge
government and ask them to think again
on legislation and I genuinely think
that is what is happening here I think
the idea that there's some Trojan horse
inside the Civil Service trying to
undermine brexit is a very bad place for
any politician to try and get into it
the violent Oakhurst Lee lady likes
having wishes thank you